by the way
physically connected in our brain this
video is brought to you by Squarespace
[Music]
foreign
good morning today I'll be trying to get
my life back on track there is an exam
and a deadline for a project that I need
to finish both in 12 days I've been
doing some active recalling just now by
doing Anki questions I usually do active
recalling either first thing in the
morning when my brain feels fresh or
right before I go to sleep because
memory consolidation happens during
sleep also I plant each day leading up
to the exam by Distributing whatever
revision that needs to get done before
the exam so I can clearly see what I
need to revise on that specific day to
finish everything on time I usually
leave the last two days blank just in
case I can't complete a task on the day
that I originally planned to do so the
last two days are there to buffer and
for me to catch up on just in case
anything doesn't go as planned so let's
get on with today's to-do list
[Music]
foreign
I put some food for you
done studying for now now we're going to
try and book a haircut appointment for
today spread your last minute so I'm not
sure if they're going to have any space
it's literally opened just now good
afternoon I was wondering if there is
any haircut appointment available for
today
[Music]
thank you
I think I'm gonna make corn dogs when I
come home today yes I'm on some do after
five so I can have some as well
[Music]
I'm outside shopping right now and I
realize I miss running errands and hang
out alone by myself this feels like a
therapy session to me especially when
it's exam season doing anything but
studying feels like a reward
[Music]
foreign
before we continue with the rest of the
day I want to present you a Squarespace
it's an incredibly Rich publishing
platform to create a website a blog or
an online store if you're a beginner
like me Squarespace makes it so easy to
help you stand out as they have
thousands of beautiful fully
customizable templates you can also
track analytics to help you understand
your viewers or buyers so you can see
where you should focus next when
creating content or developing marketing
plans I love that you can connect all
your social media accounts letting your
visitors connect with you on every major
Network so if you're interested in
creating your own site go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or a domain
[Music]
are you ready
I just got out of the hairdresser but
it's two to five p.m right now and at
five I had to teach by a fifth year
who's giving a teach on the assessment
that we have a deadline for in 12 days
so he was just going to give tips on
that and I really wanted to join I might
just join on my on my phone I really
want to go to library but
[Music]
foreign
look at my hair let me see it
oh okay it's quite good actually
you like it yeah oh you're not crying so
that's good
I'm going like that she works out the
zoom teacher's finished so I'm going to
chill for a bit but it was such a busy
day and also I've been vlogging so it
doubles the work it's so important to
take breaks and slow down especially
when you're feeling overwhelmed with
studying and everything else in life I
know it can be hard to take breaks
without feeling guilt because of all
that toxic productivity but then if I
don't enjoy my break then I'm literally
wasting it so I hope you're taking
breaks and not burning yourself out
while studying
foreign
[Music]
ly the exam I'm preparing for or I guess
cramming for is three hours long and
it's on everything that is medicine
related so we get questions on every
specialty from Cardiology to surgery to
Women's Health basically everything when
I'm getting tested on such broad
material and there is not much time left
until the exam I try to quickly bring
back all the information I learned
before by doing rapid fire questions on
all subjects in the question bank
because the chances are I won't remember
the information I Revisited in two weeks
ago if I'm short on time I'll do as less
as 15 questions on each specialty just
to stimulate my memory on that topic
because all information is physically
connected in our brain with something
called synapses so stimulating even some
of those connections by doing a few
questions about a topic should help you
remember rest of the information around
that topic as well I mean that's the
scientific theory and it works for me if
you try it out let me know how it goes
for you foreign
[Music]
I'm starving I'll eat some food then
it was a very productive day for me hope
you enjoyed it consider subscribing and
I'll see in the next one bye
[Music]